CGS it's hard you know when you're
looking at a tennis ball you you don't
get the same effect as if you were
looking at a big tall man CGI and visual
effects seem to be an important part of
filmmaking these days With a Little Help
from the actors on screen of course we
love being transported into the world of
a story through great VFX work and we
probably love watching what scenes look
like without CGI equally as much stick
around for a look at Inola home scenes
with and without CGI you get to have all
sides of the spectrum all in one movie
and it's really exciting number one hold
on to them
Inola homes features an intense sequence
on a moving train which had actors
Millie Bobby Brown and Lewis Partridge
performing a number of stunts while
walking the line between practical and
digital effects shooting the train was
tricky enough with the complicated VFX
involved but this take went down the
drain because of a simple old-fashioned
fan blowing Millie's hat off for your
best idea of any sleeping off this train
doesn't it
number two the acting is key the Enola
homes team can make the train look like
it's really speeding through the hills
but if the actors don't sell that
they're really on it the illusion falls
apart here's how actor Louis Partridge
prepares in the moment to transport
himself to the world of a speeding train
in Enola homes listen to music that was
my trick and get your breath right and
then they say action and you go and then
when you're looking at Millie and you're
both giving the same sort of energy
that's when it flows right visual
effects supervisor Michael Ellis said
that it had to feel like they were
really on the train which is quite a
hard thing to do and when we think about
it we have to agree the timing of the
Practical effects like wind or even just
the gentle rocking of the train can
easily go wrong and spoil a take when
you add in all the other moving Parts
shooting a sequence on a train is a
bigger challenge than it might first
appear Michael Ellis added of course you
can't really shoot on a a real moving
train it's a bit dangerous and kind of
heavy and people fall over we decided to
shoot it in a studio with a green screen
stage number three you gotta believe
with all the CGI involved you might be
surprised to hear that stunt performers
were used at all in this sequence Lewis
Partridge explains that he was not able
to do his own stunts when it came to
jumping off the train I'm not the Tom
Cruise that I thought I might be they
used a stunt man called James he has all
the bruises to take home James if you're
out there we're feeling for you right
now that roll down the hill looked
rattling to say the least even jumping
off of a fake moving train can be
dangerous
it just ah it just went crazy number
four everything else seems to be CGI
have a look at this scene in the various
stages of development I
Plex
part of the digital scene was made from
scans of a real environment while things
like the train were built from computers
alone we had the digital landscape we
had the Digital River and we had our
digital characters down the hill as well
that's a very digital movie they were
like whoa number five remember them
using CGI and digital effects to create
part of the world of a story is a
powerful tool but using too much of it
can make things feel like they're a
little off so what do we do add real
people back into the scene of course
after the careful process of mapping out
this scene and creating elements that
would make it convincing as an actual
place in the world it was time to add
the actors back in with an outdoor shot
I really enjoyed the Practical sets
number six goofing around on set seems
to follow Millie Bobby Brown around
green screen Studios and visual effects
are important for the experience of
Enola homes but so is the human Elements
which sometimes means the performance
and other times means keeping it real by
goofing around on set watch how fast
Millie can floss it's quite cool and
with all that green screen around just
imagine the possibilities
someone's got to take advantage of that
you
he wanted to see a lead female British
lead number seven think you'll like The
View when we think green screen and
visual effects we often think big
immersive complicated expensive but
often it's the little things that can
make the biggest differences take this
scene for example where that famous
green color can be seen only through the
window of the room where Enola is
practicing her posture with that book on
her head or this scene where the only
green screen we're actually seeing is
for the skyline or some store signs I
knew this would have a true use
number eight oh yes there's more when we
think of cable stunts we tend to think
more about Spider-Man than Enola Holmes
but believe it or not actor Lewis
Partridge is actually dangling from a
cable while on a harness in this scene
just when he's on the brink of falling
out of the train Millie Bobby Brown
actually got her hand caught in the
cable when trying to perform the action
of pulling him back through the door if
we look at this scene without CGI when
Lewis is dangling from the open door you
might notice it was actually the camera
that was on Rails speeding along and not
the train I'm not ready to go on a train
I'm not ready to die at all and I wasn't
going to before I met you number nine
who knows at this point the visual
effects team on Enola Holmes knew they
needed to have the door come off the
train for the tunnel sequence to make
this happen they needed to match the
real door with a CG door so they started
with the real door in studio mapped to
the camera movements and the actors
action carefully and then recreated the
real life door and matched it perfectly
with the CG version of itself number 10
do you believe visual effects in CGI can
have us thinking of elaborate changes to
a scene but often it can alter just a
few details that take us a little
further into believing in the world of
the story in this scene you can see just
a hint of that signature green color
indicating that production was intending
to change something there was it a sky
reflecting the mood of the scene or
maybe a store sign with a hidden clue or
message on it number 11. enolo homes
features plenty of Shining Moments where
digital meets physical sometimes the
most entertaining visual effects are
just physical performance but just like
creating an elaborate CGI sequence
physical effects take plenty of
preparation often that can mean training
and rehearsal I'm like really careful
I'm very good take this fight scene
here's what it looks like in rehearsal
with all the visual elements Stripped
Away I train for for roles that's what I
do I love training for roles number 12.
Millie Bobby Brown got more than her
hands dirty in this action sequence
check out this behind the scenes footage
where Inola Holmes wearing her new dress
gets into a scuffle with the bowler hat
in the muddy Streets of London in case
you were wondering that mud is real it's
exhausting and hard and tiring but I
actually really enjoyed it Millie went
so far as to tease someone on set with
the possibility of a very muddy wet hug
we wonder how many copies of this dress
they wound up having on hand
very very excited to be able to film it
we love watching how great CGI work can
transport an audience into the world of
the story I know it is that for me and
it's been an amazing experience creating
it and we definitely love watching the
behind the scenes just as much so what
do you think what are some of your
favorite moments without CGI